breaking news der in einem hamburger s
bahnhof ist ein mann auf die gleise
gestürzt und von einem zug erfasst
worden der mann starb noch am unfallort
und die hamburger mordkommission hat die
ermittlungen aufgenommen
deshalb schalten wir jetzt live nach
hamburg zu unserem reporter markt sieht
so an der unfallstelle
mag warum ermittelt die mordkommission
die polizei hat hier eine große
absperrung eingerichtet und erinnert hat
die mordkommission ist hier bei den
ermittlungen jetzt eingeschaltet worden
was wir jetzt gerade von der polizei
erfahren haben ist das ein radfahrer
oder ein fahrgast der sich auf dem
bahnsteig befand mit seinem fahrrad
unterwegs war und dieses ein fahrrad auf
dem bahnsteig in richtung ausgang
gegangen ist ich befinde mich jetzt hier
direkt an dem ausgang wo er eigentlich
hingehen wollte er hat dann dieses
fahrrad als roller benutzt ist dann auf
dem bahnsteig richtung ausgang gerollt
und hat dann wohl einen rempler bekommen
und ist dann gestürzt oder ins
straucheln geraten und zwischen zwei
waggons geraten und tödlich verletzt
worden
also ein rempler bekommen weil er dort
im bahnhof mit dem fahrrad sozusagen
gerollt ist und in folge dessen dann auf
die gleise gestürzt habe ich da so
richtig verstanden
ja genau also die videoaufzeichnung nach
unseren informationen haben das ergeben
dass er wohl von einer unbekannten bis
jetzt noch unbekannten personen
angerempelt worden ist und dann ins
straucheln geraten und dann zwischen
zwei waggons geraten ist und dann ja
sich tödlich verletzt hat
wie sieht die situation im moment aus
ist noch alles gesperrt
ja die polizei ist mit einem
großaufgebot vor ort die feuerwehr hat
den
toten aus dem gleis geboren und die
polizei sperrt jetzt momentan alles ab
der bahnverkehr ist auch komplett
eingestellt also auch zum hamburger
flughafen gibt es momentan keine s bahn
verbindung wir müssen gucken wie lange
das noch dauert aber die mordkommission
hat jetzt gerade erst mit den
ermittlungen angefangen und wertet auch
die videobilder aus und wird dann auch
vermutlich auch wissen welche personen
das war
vielen dank marco für die aktuellen
informationen